[Music]  [Music]  we're not nice women when Colossus would  take money for small-minded men he's the  mark he's our tech millionaire if this  person would just scoot over  would you mind sir sir Sir what's min  says no doubt he's a terrible shot  expected I'm having a bit of a [ __ ]  when I first met and when I posted this  panting why are women better suited to  the calm than men because we're used to  faking it many beliefs underestimate us  and that is what we used is it valuable  $500,000 I like it cuz it's shiny I  could be the positive and you need to  teach me you're sure the baby weighs so  much mean sighs there's nothing more  compelling to a man than a vulnerable  woman Wow you just tear up no uplay are  you constipated I'm a babe we're not  nice women we're con artists let her get  away  she did it again  minute Boyd us so let's reverse it we  exploit a man  he's our tech millionaire try to be  inconspicuous his person will just scoot  over  would you mind sir sir  you